hello welcome I'm Melinda crane and
here's what's on this week's agenda
Syrian refugees wide open doors in
Sweden but our other countries doing
enough Syrians split at the g20
diplomatic tobacco for Germany and
jubilant japan wins its bid for the 2020
olympics but could fukushima spoil the
show and we have three expert guests
here ready to lock horns over this
week's headlines and what's behind them
starting with Carmen Schmidt she's an
expert on Japanese politics who teaches
political sociology at the University of
osnabrück and also serves a speaker of
its Japan Research Center and we're
pleased to welcome Marcus crime he is
head of international security research
at the prestigious German Institute for
International and security affairs he's
also an adjunct professor at the
University of Zurich and he's taught in
Germany Canada and the US and finally
it's a pleasure to welcome Susanna
schmelter she is the author of several
studies on the situation of Syrian
refugees she's currently writing her PhD
at the University of goettingen and she
attended the University of Damascus
until shortly before the crisis began so
since we've got two Syrian topics on
this week's agenda and we've been
hearing the drums of war beating ever
louder the last couple of weeks I'd like
to start out by asking all of you one
short question and it is in regard to
this newest proposal that we're seeing
from Syria and Russia that Syria should
give its chemical weapons into
international control by the UN for
example who among you actually believes
that a political solution to this crisis
is possible Carmen well I think maybe we
can avoid the military strike now but
whether this will lead to a political
solution I'm a bit skeptical about that
Marcus Cambodia SEC fully agreed the
notion the Russian initiative if fully
implemented will maybe
help to control this chemical stockpile
of Syria but it does not provide any
political solution to the civil war in
Syria and susannah schmelter me I agree
and I'm skeptical that this vellum gives
away free to a political solution but
it's maybe first step towards a
political solution and if there's any
possibility to avoid a military strike
think it's necessary to take it because
in my opinion military strike would only
further escalate the situation in the
region images of dead children poisoned
by gas have brought home the staggering
human toll in Syria but there is another
measure of that whole less visible to
many of us who live outside the region
and that's the mass displacement of the
living almost one third of the country's
population has been uprooted in what the
UN refugee agency recently called the
great tragedy of this century are those
who are arriving on European shores
getting the help they need Germany says
it will offer sanctuary to five thousand
Syrians from this month it is taking in
more refugees than any other European
country apart from Sweden Germany has
received praise for its help but the
Welcome is not always friendly most
Syrian refugees are living in makeshift
camps in neighboring states and the
total number of people in need is
staggering the United Nations says at
least two million Syrians have fled
their country what is appalling is that
the first million fled Syria during two
years the second million fled Syria in
six months as the conflict continues the
exodus is sure to persist and the
humanitarian problem will worsen where
will all serious refugees go
susannah schmelter tell us first of all
please what you're hearing from friends
and acquaintances in Damascus are they
making plans to leave yes they make
plans to leave they try to leave some
have left already they stay now in
Lebanon Turkey and others try
desperately to live and have very few
opportunities to do so von frontier has
a Palestinian background and for him the
borders to the neighboring states are
mainly closed he could go to Lebanon but
the living expenses I expensive there
and from there he also doesn't know
where to go he often often asked me what
to do and he tells me the journey to
Europe would cost ten thousand dollars
and I feel helpless and he's completely
stuck and I have another friend who has
many connections to Europe he has even a
Schengen visa and he tried to transfer
his business here but still he has a
family was two small kids and he had
difficulties to open my business here
and even if he comes here and applies
for asylum it would take too long time
to leave his family alone there to apply
for family reunification and so on so
they are in very different situations
but they they have very few
opportunities to leave the country and
they all changed already the houses in
in serious em safe so they are
internally displaced already now we have
just heard Germany has made this offer
to take in 5000 Syrian refugees how
satisfied are you with that response
when it's a good step in the right
direction but it's certainly not enough
seem that there are two million people
outside Syria and of more precarious
desperate conditions that many try to go
to to Europe to access Europe via for
example the Aegean Sea they're often
dying in the Mediterranean and there I
see a kind of hippocras that Germany
presents itself now as a good
humanitarian actor which is good step
but on the other hand
you're beeps people to die in front of
its own borders just to put that number
that 5,000 in perspective Marcus come
5,000 is actually the number that leaves
Syria in one day one day now a Green
Party politician here in Germany has
just said your Germany should be taking
in not 5,000 but 50,000 but frankly
isn't that a bit delusional given the
fact that we're seeing demonstrations
right here in Berlin against an asylum
center for just a couple of hundred
asylum seekers I'm not sure about the
specific numbers which can be accepted
here in Germany but think that the point
is is is right that we see a lack of
political leadership I mean on the one
hand the foreign policy establishment
clearly has stated over the last two
years Syria is facing one of the worst
humanitarian disasters we have seen in
the last 20 years in the European
neighborhood or European periphery but
and at the same time we're accepting
only a handful of refugees and one side
narrative of the debate is that at least
for a certainty to a certain degree the
politicians dis over the political class
has focused on Christian refugees being
accepted Christian Syrian refugees being
accepted to Germany and I think the
overarching approach should be inclusive
as as inclusive as possible and not
specific not focusing on specific
religious groups common Schmidt good
arguments but the fact is refugee
numbers have already been rising to
Germany because of the economic crisis
in southern Europe we've seen a great
deal more immigration this year so is it
really realistic to think Germany is
going to open its doors wider to the
Syrians I don't think that it's
realistic to take 50,000 or something
like that but the 5,000 are a good step
but given the fact that we have two
million refugees I think the number is
too small so we should take more
refugees but I think we need a European
perspective on this match I think let's
talk a bit more about that European
picture Susannah schmelter as we heard
in our report Sweden has
said it's going to open its doors wide
it's going to give residency to any
Syrian refugee who makes it to Sweden
why can't other European countries take
the same approach it's a good question
well sweden had already in the iraqi
refugee crisis quite liberal policies to
us towards refugees and after some time
it came more restrictive because other
EU member state did not do a like or
share this responsibility so i think
also now a Sweden needs to to have other
states in Europe who support those
policies by accepting also refugees
because like this all refugees would try
to come to Sweden because as I would
have most perspectives but the fact is
though it's not that difficult for
Sweden to make this kind of offer
because it is not the point of first
entry yeah for most Syrian refugees is
it can you explain that system to us you
mentioned it briefly they tend to be
coming by water through the
Mediterranean that means they wind up in
countries like Italy isn't it barring a
much greater burden here and you border
states like Greece Italy maybe Im try to
come by a big area they and I usually
applied to except for Greece there's a
regulation that people who enter Europe
via Greece are not referred back to
Greece but usually the stab line
regulation says that the asylum claim
has to be preceded in the country where
they've arrived so it's true that Sweden
or Germany don't receive an asylum
claims like this but still people try to
go to these countries because the
prospect for getting exact acceptance
are still higher than in those countries
Marvis con carmen Schmidt said we need a
European solution to this what are the
prospects that we're going to get that I
mean with the
the the the pillars of a European
migration and asylum policy but as you
have indicated the perspectives of
different EU member states are very
different with the countries in the the
Nordic countries will have a traditional
history of accepting refugees since
world war two being very open but there
as you have said they are not affected
by the huge numbers countries like Italy
like Greece and have to shoulder the the
the the biggest part of the burden of
the European refugee flow refugee flow
into the European Union and at the at
the end of the day European governments
emphasize to certain degree it's the
part of national sovereignty to
determine who's coming in and who's
who's left out if you look at some of
these Nordic countries biggest
challenges in the years to come Carmen
Schmidt you might think they would be
welcoming refugees namely the
demographic issue all of the Northern
European countries are facing shrinking
aging populations couldn't immigrants
and apparently many of the Syrian
immigrants tend to be well educated
immigrants couldn't they be an answer
yeah sure that can be an answer and as
you said a lot of them are really have
good education and so we can meet them
surely and I think that is good idea yes
I think it can be an answer to one part
but the refugee policies should be for
people in need it should not focus to
get only the well-educated and to leave
the others out there still other
programs for migration and I think they
should be used properly and people
usually don't want to become refugees
they would prefer to go as normal
micron's to get a working visa any kind
of visa so it would be good to to
channel the just variant e2 to give give
visa to the people can work with an
education student visa and so on and the
rest is for refugee status should be for
the people who are need to
maybe not useful for the Society of the
now surely let us briefly because we're
coming to the end of this particular
part of our discussion but let us
briefly returned to the region itself
the Middle East as we mentioned earlier
the greatest burden of course is falling
on those neighbouring countries to Syria
Lebanon Jordan Marc Marquez crime these
are very poor countries especially
Jordan one of the walls lowest amounts
of water in the world in Jordan Jordan
has taken in an equivalent of refugees
as if 33 million Mexicans had arrived on
us shores what does this mean for the
political stability in the region as a
whole to have these huge streams of
refugees actually needs a surprise that
the political systems of the neighboring
countries are still pretty stable I mean
they have to absorb you huge numbers of
refugees in a very short time which is a
burden not in economic terms not only in
economic terms but also in terms of
social durability and cut social
cohesion for for societies which are
already fragmented long ethnic and
religious lines and how this already has
a fact that other neighboring countries
can be seen what we call what we look to
Lebanon and we will look at Iraq I mean
the Syrian civil war is not only civil
war anymore it has spread already to
Lebanon and at least to Lebanon and Iraq
and it runs danger to to affect John and
Turkey as well and it's become a war of
religion across the entire region one
last question to you Susanna schmelter
are these refugee flows actually a
reflection of a reality that we do not
want to face namely that the Middle East
is being reshaped into Sunni and Shiite
zones and that there is essentially
ethnic cleansing going on there well I
think it's difficult to read it like
this because it tends to to stress those
fault lines in again but it's true that
this the whole conflict was am is
getting more and more fought along the
sectarian lines
and that and there's also get the
fragmentation of the Syrian society and
also that refugees look ver to go over
they have relatives or members of the
same religious community so there might
really be some reshaping this directory
thank you very much well it's not only
the refugee side of the Syrian crisis
that is testing diplomatic metal at last
week's g20 summit leaders argued over
Syria late into the night and Germany at
least found itself with strange
bedfellows the next morning casting its
lot with Russia China Brazil and
Argentina rather than its EU partners
it's not the first time the diplomatic
indecision left Chancellor Merkel
looking like a professional fence sitter
at last week's g20 summit in Russia
Germany didn't sign Chancellor Angela
Merkel was the only major EU leader not
to back a u.s. initiative blaming the
Syrian government for a chemical attack
on civilians just a day later after a
meeting of EU foreign ministers attended
by US Secretary of State John Kerry
Germany made a u-turn and decided to
sign after all speaking at an election
campaign event Merkel defended the late
signing last once Alice tahun that's
nine we had to do everything possible to
get a joint position of the 28 member
states and we succeeded we can be proud
of that and then we could sign the g20
declaration it's one see Jackie Evancho
scribe it's not the first time that
Germany has seemed to wobble over
military intervention in crisis areas in
2011 it abstained on a Security Council
resolution for a no-fly zone over Libya
marcos critics say she's a Vasa later
others say Germany is taking a moral
stance his Germany on a zigzag course on
major foreign policy issues Marcus Conda
shilly-shallying at the g20 and
afterward was eerily reminiscent of
Germany stance on Libya what's going on
here I think two points are maybe
important first for the United States
and other countries is it's easy to
ignore germany german germany's foreign
and security policy can be ignored it's
simply not important anymore Germany is
important in economic terms with regards
to European integration and the European
recovery after the debt financial crisis
international financial crisis but in
terms of foreign security policy it's
it's possible to neglect Germany and the
second point is it is that where Germany
ought to be as Europe's most important
economic absolutely my view of Germany's
punching below its weight not above its
weight and it's not for the first time
that the German political class was
confronted with very specific and very
high expectations towards taking a clear
stand on a certain issue and at least
currently know what he's talking about a
military contribution but about a clear
political standpoint about the situation
in Syria let's take a brief look at
exactly what was at stake at the g20
there was this declaration it did
contain one sentence that could possibly
be construed as support for the u.s.
even if it went ahead with military
action now given the fact that we're in
the middle of an election campaign and
that Germans are notoriously shy about
military power wasn't it quite
understandable that angle America wasn't
going to sign that but actually the
German government is facing the same
problem of credibility and the US
president is facing I mean the German
government has emphasized for the last
two years or even more President Assad
must go his time is
is up he has to leave his office and has
made very clear which side the German
government is on in Syria and at the end
of the day that means that ermengarde
the German Germany has to take a clear
point with regard to the to the use of
chemical weapons in Syria and the
political prospects and that was has
been the problem in Vilnius regardless
of the question of the cohesion of the
European foreign policy let me ask our
other two guests how they see it would
you want your country to sign on to a
sentence in a declaration that possibly
could be construed as supporting
military action Carmen Schmidt
personally not and I think what the
Chairman's did was to say we need a
European line we discussed this with our
European partners but there were the
European partners were there in Moscow
at the g20 meeting couldnt they have
discussed it there okay but they had an
meeting day after and they wanted to
rate such a position and I think it's
very good if we say we want to have
Europe then we should have a Europe
foreign policy and not determine policy
and so I think it was quite
understandable Susanna schmelter
couldn't one also make quite a different
argument the argument that's
traditionally made here is we had a
terrible experience with military power
we perpetrated terrible crimes and we
refuse to get involved in using military
power again but couldn't you also look
at this the other way around and say a
country that gassed millions of people
is one of the first that should sign up
to strong efforts to prevent the use of
chemical weapons ever again think it
would against this background it would
be good to be very reluctant to take
military action and for this reason I
think it's good that they refrained from
backing the US that's strongly but and
Germany has no other position it has no
clear strategy treat over at the Syrian
conflict and
it should have said set on on means to
find a peaceful solution or decides of
early early strategy to talk I'm kind of
situation or maybe even for military
action but in this situation it's it's
going to escalate I think but but it's
good that I mean Germany should jazz
it's not two partners it has to show
some consistency and its position and to
stand besides its partners this is
really problematic part also Marcos can
could you say that Germany in some ways
learned the wrong lessons for history
from history or learned them too well
and has been unable to adapt to its new
circumstances I mean we had the debate
about what to learn from our history you
were very specifically with regards to
the Kosovo decision fifteen years ago
when the question when the Green Party
almost split exactly on the one hand you
had those saying our Nazi past our
military past requires us to be on the
other side of those who are looking for
political solutions and on the other
side you had those arguing particularly
because of our historical burdens we
have to fold a specific responsibility
to avoid cases like Wanda like scary
needs are like Libya and a situation
like in Syria that can lead to very
uncomfortable hard decision making and
that is this cuff which has never ended
in some ways Germany almost seems to
have backtracked since that time in
Kosovo one of the very strong arguments
made at that time was what Susanna
schmelter also just said it's not only
the letter of the law that counts it's
not only this pedantic attachment
perhaps too abstract principles but also
what are your friends doing what are
your allies doing which side you want to
be on it sometimes seems that Germany
has moved backward from from that
was taken in cost and and additionally
it's a question of morale orientation I
mean as a sentence like to be a force
for good in the world it's it's a
sentence or self description which is
used in the United States the United
States it's a force for good in there in
the international system and then the UK
as well but it's this notion has been
never accepted in in Germany as well and
as he as you have said the problem has
been since Libya the one of the worst
nightmares for german foreign policy
since world war two to be on the wrong
side against our traditional Western
allies and be on the side of those
countries which the the rising powers in
the international system India Brazil
China but at the end of the day did not
pay off China India and Brazil reacted
more irritated than than happy to be to
be embraced by Germany and in many ways
that club that Germany joined by not
signing at the g20 Carmen Schmidt is a
club of countries very unwilling to take
responsibility countries that we often
call for china for example to become a
stakeholder in the system is Germany
itself acting enough as a stakeholder in
the international system well when we
are talking about this third case we
should say that if Germany have learned
something from the past is that we
should wait what the UN Commission will
say on that investigation was it gasps
who has done this and so I think that we
should await this investigation and then
decide on that matter and one more thing
that international law does not back any
military strike not even in the case of
such a gas attack it can't be over it
has to be condemned but it does not say
that we should give a military strike to
someone Marcus cannon are there not
chapter 7 UN Charter arguments that can
be made if it's proven that
country has used chemical weapons
absolutely the situation in Syria even
without the use of chemical weapons can
all could be qualified as an threat to
international security but it's up to
after the UN Security Council to qualify
it as a threat to international security
and authorize all necessary measures
according to chapter 7 Susanna schmelter
do you really believe the UN is capable
of taking meaningful action here we
haven't seen it to do so in the past two
years Russia completely blocking action
in the Security Council when you look at
your friends and their suffering in
Syria do you really have any faith that
the UN can sort the simple not really no
seems to be quite dead look at the
moment that there's a block
constellation with Russia on the one
side you at us and different allies but
it's really difficult to get a political
solution in Syria and it's actually far
beyond Syria the conflict is not only
Syrian conflict so many different actors
are I intertwined in this constellation
and that it's difficult but finally it
has to be found them and in maybe in the
Security Council even I mean at least
the big players have to get on the table
to the international players certainly
Marcos can we are seeing some movement
now in terms of the Russian and Syrian
proposal that we mentioned at the top of
the show what do you think is it a
delaying tactic or might it actually be
able to defuse at least the issue around
the chemical weapons I think the
initiative has taken off the option of a
military strike from the table it for
understandable reasons the US president
will will be happy to embrace the
Russian initiative as always in politics
the question is in the details under
which circumstances are this chemical
weapons stockpile is this topple handed
over to the United Nations who's going
to supervise the
the abolition of this chemical weapons
who's going to pay for it how long does
it take and so on and so on and the
biggest problem is the civil war with
more than 110,000 people being killed
unfortunately it will continue coming
Schmidt are you hopeful that we will see
a way out that does not involve military
action I am hopeful yes but maybe this
is just a hope but we have seen that
something is moving and so I hope that
this is a first step and that we can see
a political solution in the future thank
you very much well questions like who
can you trust how credible is the
information that we're getting from our
leaders those questions are at the very
heart of the debate over Syria's
chemical weapons and what to do about
them and they're also key issues in our
third story on today's program Japanese
leaders are counting on the 2020
Olympics to boost the country's economic
upswing and to prove that it's back on
top after two lost decades but are they
giving us the full story on further
fallout from Fukushima just last month
the Japanese government announced plans
to restart nuclear power stations shut
down since the 2011 earthquake and
tsunami that caused them meltdown at the
Fukushima plant now the latest alarming
data from Fukushima shows that the
nuclear complex is leaking much more
radioactivity than the operator TEPCO
previously claimed South Korea has
responded to the news by banning imports
of fish caught in the Fukushima region
but japanese prime minister shinzo ave
insists the situation is under control
his assurances at least convinced the
International Olympic Committee which
awarded the Olympic Games to Tokyo will
Fukushima be under control in time for
the 2020 Olympics coach Schmidt to those
assurances convince you is Fukushima
stable and secure absolutely not and I
have two concerns at the moment the one
we have seen here is other leaks so it
was confirmed that we have leaks with a
radioactive coolant water that leaked
into the ocean and with well a lot of
radiation going into the water and we
have seen that the South Korea has bend
fishery products from eight Japanese
prefectures and the next point is that
in November tap code tries to remove the
spent fuel rods from reactor number four
and this is a very urgent task because
that building is in a very bad situation
and every small quake can lead to a
collapse and if they are removing this
spent fuel rods they contain deadly
plutonium this is a very delicate task
because usually it needs you need the
help of computers but now it has to be
done manually because it's damaged and
if something does go wrong this can
really lead to a catastrophe on the
other hand 2020 is quite a ways off
Japan has some of the world's top
scientists and research experts working
on this problem and it's very much in
their interest to get it under control
are you not confident that they're going
to be able to do so well I have the hope
that with that decision the Japanese
government will do its utmost to get
things under control and i also do hope
that they will come back to the global
community to seek for help
to get things under control but i think
that the olympic games will be a good
point Microscan our proposed seeking
help from the international community
apparently a german expert recently
refused to visit this site saying that
he was concerned for his personal safety
would that seem to you to be an
overreaction here I'm not an expert on
the situation in Fukushima in particular
but it seems to be a more political
problem at for the future for for Japan
I mean what I read and hear about the
relationship between the government the
supervising authorities for the nuclear
sector and the the the power company
tepco reminds me of something which we
actually know that from developed
countries but from third world countries
which we call bad governance in which
there's obviously at least to a certain
degree no necessary amount of
transparency control accountability and
that that is from in my view the biggest
problem regardless of the current
situation in Fukushima Japanese
prosecutors interestingly enough Carmen
that Schmidt that just this week decided
not to charge TEPCO bosses in connection
with the initial phase of the disaster
seems surprising is this just a cultural
issue or is there a profound lack of
accountability here it's very hard to
say who is accountable for that because
there were also political reasons for
that and as he said the controlling was
very bad and things like that that did
not take into consideration that there
might be a tsunami is that the
responsibility of TEPCO or was it a
political responsibility and so I think
it's quite understandable Suzanne wish
matter how would you feel about say
visiting that region at the moment would
you would you worry about your personal
safety or would you trust the Japanese
assurances no after all what I've heard
I would be wearing I'm also not an
expert about the risks and
it yeah what exactly is going on and one
which degrees it might be harmful or not
but it makes me worried I wouldn't go
there would you eat some fish no no but
now let's take a little full Marcus
crime would you eat fish from that
region as we just heard Korea talking
about issuing a ban would you eat that
fish would you trust it I wonder how
easy it is to identify a fish from this
particularly region but however and I
would try to avoid it I'd like to I'd
like to come well we'll just find out if
Carmen Schmidt would eat the fish first
I'll do the pole I don't do that fish
yeah I tried to avoid it yes let me come
back to the cultural issue there was a
report issued by a parliamentary
commission in Japan saying that
Fukushima was a man-made disaster
because of Japan's quote culture of
reflexive obedience are you seeing any
signs that that has been followed up on
that that culture of reflexive obedience
to higher ups through hierarchies is
changing that is definitely changing yes
I think this is changing and but I don't
think that we should say this is a
culture or something like that it was a
man-made disaster it was not taken into
consideration the specific situation in
Japan with the earthquakes and tsunamis
and things like that and I don't think
that we can say this has some cultural
background and what is to say with
nuclear energy that many Japanese back
nuclear energy and this is because Japan
lacks gas other natural resources like a
sword or something like that and it was
cheap cheap energy they are of course
now bringing nuclear plants back online
how much support for that is there
within Japan well as I said before the
disaster many Japanese backed or
maturity back that since the disaster
this changed dramatically today around
eighty percent of all Japanese say that
they want to phase out nuclear energy on
the other hand nearly seventy percent
say that some of the reactors have to be
brought bring back online to secure
power so it's a little bit a mixed
picture but what we see and that it's
good it's a growing awareness concerning
nuclear power concerning the
alternatives and the pros and cons and
so I think this is a positive situation
interestingly enough when we talk about
what changed after Fukushima one of the
places that changed its policy most
drastically Susanna schmelter was your
own country here in Germany the energy
venda the shift toward renewables away
from nuclear away from fossil fuels is
itself running into some trouble now are
you expecting to see a backlash here in
your own country as well necklace
towards nuclear energy no backlash away
from the energy vendor I am well I think
it's good that they in a given is coming
and it was probably the the point which
really made it made it coming but well
it's a long way I hope it will be
successful and that they have enough
patience also because it's a small only
small percentage of the general energy
but I think it's worth and exploring it
and am up mounting the amount of of any
natural energies but yeah Marcus can't
we've seen the energy vendor called into
question during the election campaign
here in Germany at the moment was it
ultimately an overreaction by your
country to Fukushima and would you
expect to see major changes after the
election I don't expect major changes in
terms of returning to a new clarity but
I think now a lot of people have more
see simply see the consequences of the
in a given and now I'll get a more let's
call it more sober perspective that the
na given amines also higher energy
prices
and for a lot of your German holes
households that is an issue not for the
high-income households but for the
low-income households so the question of
energy you and in a given their has
become now the election campaign an
issue for the sofa or has been connected
with Social Security and that I think
will define the Atlanta for the next
four years to come returning to Japan
but staying with that economic theme
Carmen Schmidt Japan as I mentioned
earlier has faced two decades of
recession zero growth very big economic
problems many people of course hoping
that the Olympics will pull Japan out of
this dark long phase do you think it's
right can it do that I'm not sure where
that really can do that but I want to
come back to one thing that Japan is on
its way to renewable energy or greening
Japan we should not oversee that fact
even though the Japanese government is
pro nuclear power but what's going on
behind the surface is really impressive
because if we see what is happening
Japan is now behind China the second
fastest growing market for solar energy
and when it comes to the capacities that
are already installed it's just behind
Germany and Italy so it's very
impressive it's just a start but we see
a greening of Japan so people taking
renewable seriously how seriously are
they taking these olympic games as a
boost as a sign japan is back that's
what we're being told is it true that
the population feel that way yeah if you
look at Tokyo the people are celebrating
this decision so for the people it's
something yeah going back to normal and
that's very important for them so yes
and many have the hope that yeah I would
boost the economy of course the Japanese
government want to show the world we
have overcome a crisis very severe
crisis and so of course for the people
it's
a good thing and they are celebrating
Marcus can what do you think you can
Olympics can be a two-edged sword would
you expect that they will really do for
Japan what Japan is hoping I mean it
depends I mean we have a couple of cases
from the past in which countries pay a
lot of money for the for the
infrastructure and after the end of the
Olympic Games the the stadiums were
simply ruins there were have been never
been used again so it's a question of
proper planning and from my view from
what I see the London the last olympic
games in london have to be seemed to be
very successful in terms of investment
into infrastructure but for example
Montreal in the 1970s economic and
disaster and disaster in terms of
infrastructure Susannah schmelter very
briefly asked you if you would eat the
fish from Japan would you travel to
Japan for the games I would I think
thanks very much to all of you for being
with us today and thanks to all of our
viewers out there for tuning in don't
forget you can watch the show again
online just go to our website that's DW
de / english / agenda and do write us a
mail and tell us what you think bye-bye
you